[Aplausos]
[Música]
ao longo da minha vida eu sempre fui
tida como uma pessoa bastante pessimista
né
apesar de eu deu me reconhecer como ser
absolutamente realista
enquanto a cientista social informação
eu tenho uma mania de querer da
explicação pra absolutamente tudo que
acontece na minha vida tentando dar
explicação para as pessoas dizerem nada
você é muito pessimista
parece que você vê a sua vida por um
filtro em que tudo é fatalidade em que
toda desgraça tentando entender de onde
surgiu eu comecei a olhar o meu passado
entender qual é essa realidade e
construir que faz com que eu tenha esse
olhar absolutamente destrutivo pra para
o mundo para o mundo ao meu redor e pra
minha existência principalmente eu
sempre fui uma criança muito crua sabe
quando as pessoas perguntavam o que você
quer ser quando crescer eu ia quinta
lava e me sentia bastante confusa e
desacreditada com amigos meus diziam eu
quero centronautico bola estavam
querendo se instalar a eu quero sê sei
lá
a opep motorista de avião e falei tá bom
humor em perus como uma pobre né
e esses sentimentos de realidade de
limites eles sempre tiveram muito claro
pra mim hoje em dia por exemplo quando
eu penso é no meu futuro é hoje em dia o
lugar que ocupa o lugar em que eu
conquistei muito mais do que eu achei
que eu poderia não é que eu tenho muito
mais do que eu achei que conseguiria e
quando às vezes eu me pego olhando para
o futuro eu percebo o quanto eu não
espero muito mais
o coi já estou um pouco satisfeita e dá
uma satisfação no sentido de que estou
bem com que eu tenho sentido de a cura
são mesmo
isso tudo me fez perceber e pensar como
o racismo foi destruindo minha
capacidade de sonhar
a minha capacidade de imaginar
possibilidades futuras para mim e para
pessoas como eu
isso pode parecer muito simples né
sonhar na tréplica viver e sonhar não
entender por que é importante sonhar
por que é importante construir dez
edições
eu sei que muitos muitos de vocês quando
criança tinha um determinado os desejos
vocês queriam ser professores vocês
queriam crescer mais se desenvolver mais
que isso não necessariamente é a
realidade de muitas pessoas negras e eu
quando criança tinha uma relação
bastante contraditória com isso porque
ao mesmo tempo em que eu me tornei uma
pessoa muito realista como forma de me
posicionar frente à realidade
eu também sempre gostei muito de ficção
científica eu sempre gostei muito de
pensar em alternativas e universos
paralelos em formas de experimentar a
sociedade a tecnologia e qualquer tipo
de defunto azia ou de imaginação que não
necessariamente faltasse materialismo em
que a gente vive e é bastante
contraditório essas são uma das
contradições que constroem enquanto um
ser humano para ser humano são
contraditórias e eu comecei a pensar meu
deus como eu amo perceber as
possibilidades que nós temos de existir
no mundo enquanto outras pessoas né
para um de nós iremos de onde nós viemos
quais são os nossos objetivos quais são
os nossos os nossos propósitos da terra
essas perguntas me perseguiram durante a
adolescência inteira e conforme a
perguntando nossos propósitos nossos
objetivos e eu comecei a perceber que se
nós aí tinha um problema bem grande pra
mim eu não conseguia talvez me enxergar
eu me sentia representada por esse nós
enquanto raça humana afinal a galera
aqui no planeta terra tão longe de mim
mas ao mesmo tempo eu não enxergava
nesse nós enquanto uma mulher e negra
tia que se nós e de onde viemos para
onde vamos
não contemplavam as minhas experiências
não contemplava a forma como enxergar
bem posicionado no mundo e foi aí que
nas minhas leituras e divagações que nas
minhas passagens pelo ativismo negro e
por para as outras coisas que eles
construíram enquanto indivíduo que eu
consigo conheci um conceito muito
importante chamado a profuturo mesmo o
futurismo é um conceito muito simples é
tão simples que vocês vão chocar é
basicamente a idéia radical de pessoas
negras existem no futuro
o futurismo na verdade ele entrou na
minha vida por meio da literatura quando
realmente é um termo que surgiu em 1994
nos estados unidos
coincidentemente um ano do meu
nascimento acho que isso é um sinal e
logo o futurismo acaba sendo uma das
coisas que mais mexem comigo e mais me
envolvem nos dias de hoje guiam a minha
trajetória
o futurismo ele é um movimento mas eu
prefiro pensar como conceito com uma
filosofia que pensa na arte na música na
dança na política na filosofia na
literatura no cinema em todas as áreas
possíveis da existência humana
a existência negra e uma existência
negra afastada de construções tidas como
primitivas e arcaicas porque a gente
quando geralmente a gente pensa em
pessoas negras
a gente pensou naquele tambor ea gente
pensa em artesanal a gente pensa em
áfrica como se fosse um outro espaço um
país distante para o turismo vai colocar
pessoas negras no tempo presente
principalmente no futuro ele vai ver que
essas pessoas constroem coisas tão
sofisticadas como qualquer outra pessoa
presente que essas pessoas por serem
negras africanas ou negras de históricas
nosso caso br estão construindo coisas é
próximas às tecnologias mais esperadas e
imaginava imaginadas no país até quando
falta tecnologia não estou falando
necessariamente de celular estão de
tecnologia no sentido de ferramentas
para transformar são um dos grandes
nomes do automobilismo quer apresentar
para vocês hoje é esse cara chamado são
raros
ele era o futurista muito antes disso
seu mundinho muito antes as pessoas
chamarem e ligia futurista
sam é um músico músico estadunidense
muito importante movimento futurista ele
vai dizer que o planeta terra é bastante
cruel que no planeta terra em qualquer
tempo e espaço a pessoas negras irão
sofrer
então se o grande mote é que pessoas
negras africanas de históricas saíssem
do planeta terra e fossem ribeiro e
outros universos em outros espaços
essa era uma idéia fantasiosa que guiava
todas as produções de som ao longo da
sua trajetória da sua carreira ele dizia
ele tinha um lema pra mim é um tema
muito importante e falava space e depois
o espaço alugar o espaço seu espaço há
lugar para pessoas negras crie um espaço
alugado para pessoas negras existam um
outro grande nome é o que teve a bater
essa mulher que tanto admiro o que teve
um grande nome da literatura afro
futurista é uma mulher que na sua
primeira obra na sobra de inauguração no
ar o futurismo que investe dá um tapa na
cara e acerta as contas de anos e anos
com a ficção científica clássica e vai
falar sobre essa mulher que nos desse
livro que está bem aqui e vai falar
sobre essa protagonista negra afro
americana que se vê forçada a viajar no
tempo e quando essa mulher viaja no
tempo ela encontra em todos os espaços
em que ela acaba acessando perigos de
vida morte o que é bastante
contraditório quando a gente vê uma
ficção científica não sei quantos de
vocês aqui tem familiaridade com esse
gênero na literatura em viagem no tempo
é algo absolutamente divertido é
absolutamente absurdo absolutamente
fácil obteve alta da produção científica
com uma realidade com uma realidade crua
é como seria uma mulher negra viajar no
tempo e por exemplo para o brasil
colonial sendo negra o que optei viação
raehk outros autores e outros performers
e outras pessoas a profuturo estas me
trazem é um sentimento muito grande de
qual é o lugar da pessoa negra no
universo e principalmente no futuro
o que nós temos a oferecer para onde nós
iremos necessariamente nós no sentido
negros
eles me fazem perguntar se existe no
mundo inteiro o lugar seguro para
pessoas negras existirem existe no mundo
inteiro em qualquer tempo espaço um
lugar em que as pessoas negras não
necessariamente vão morrer
não necessariamente vamos subir julgadas
quando eu penso talvez em homens negros
eu consigo pensar em algumas épocas mas
em mulheres realmente é humano e não há
espaço no planeta terra e nenhum tempo
presente passado e talvez futuro em que
mulheres negros estejam seguras
aí só é muito pessimista é basicamente a
realidade existe uma resposta para isso
se o passado é um problema que o futuro
se o presente também ao problema seria
então o futuro a nossa única saída
eu vou com saha e eu acredito que apesar
de muito fantasiosa a ideia de espécies
de plays ela acaba sendo mais realista
porque ela encara a realidade atual como
algo cru como algo
puro como realmente é como as espécies
de players como assim a única resposta
pra pra que nos livremos do racismo das
opressões que nós sofremos enquanto
pessoas negras é sair do planeta terra
talvez não saibam inglaterra mas talvez
construir um futuro mais justo construir
um futuro feliz um futuro otimista eu
acho que são rápido ele nega o passado e
quando ele nega esse presente mostrando
que esse presente esse passado não são
feitos por pessoas negras existirem ele
nos não necessariamente nos da alma uma
visão surrealista é absolutamente
abstrata sobre como será o futuro mas
ele nos mostra que é possível construir
outras realidades fora do que nós
ora o que nós já temos
e aí é que nós temos a clássica ficção
científica eu acho que vocês devem
acompanhar star wars nos grandes
clássicos como nós analisamos o que é
ficção científica quando nós observamos
é o que é construído a gente estava
percebendo que a ficção científica é um
lugar povoado por pessoas brancas futuro
é isto se essa é a visão de futuro que
nós temos estamos construindo as pessoas
negras morreram absolutamente né
nós não ajudamos a construir casas nós
não estamos dirigindo novas espaçonaves
espaciais
nós não estamos nos envolvendo com novas
tecnologias
nós não estamos produzindo conhecimento
nós não estamos participando de
construções de novas tecnologias né
se existe um futuro e esse é o futuro
retratado na cultura pop
o genocídio aconteceu e não existem
pessoas negras lindas né
desde filmes há desenhos infantis o mais
interessante sobre isso é que vocês vão
me dizer natalie
mas tudo isso é ficção que isso tem a
ver com a realidade afinal é ficção mas
o futuro também na ficção o futuro real
porto não é real futuro uma construção
mental
o futuro é uma idéia é baseada em
experiências passadas e expectativas
presentes o futuro uma história contada
pelas mesmas pessoas que afirmam que
apresente hoje homens brancos
o futuro é na verdade algo muito próximo
às nossas realizações atuais ao que nós
escolhemos dizer e fazer enquanto
população enquanto terráqueos
mas natalie
ainda assim é só ficção é bem se você
quer ver só com uma ficção que fixam
racista do caramba né ficção intensa é
essa que realmente acha que pessoas
negras estão mortas que ficção é essa
que usam um ou dois personagens negros
como alegorias narrativas né eu não sei
se vocês conhecem muito desse mundo
desse gênero mas sempre tem em algumas
secções stop casa aquela ideia de de
contextos inabitáveis e eu vejo pessoas
negras neste mesmo espaço pessoas negras
são tão raras na ficção científica
quanto é a água e quanto a terra feita
para ser cultivada porque a gente está
falando em realidade pós apocalípticas
mas que ficção centífica racista essa né
na melhor das hipóteses ela é racista e
ela nega a existência de pessoas negras
por ignorância porque talvez quem faça
não sabe as pessoas negras existem
grande maioria no mundo e na pior das
hipóteses essa ficção científica
expressa um desejo íntimo escondido de
um futuro que seja sua popular por
pessoas brancas
eu quero apresentar para vocês um afro
futurista no tempo presente no tempo no
espaço presentes e fábio cabral ele é
escritor negro brasileiro ele lançou
recentemente aqui o seu personagem
principal de sua obra o caçador da rua
13 e 14 cabral tem um dos conceitos ele
tem uma das conceitualização as mais
importantes sobre o futurismo que eu
tive acesso que eu pude ler
ele disse que esse movimento de
transformar o presente recriar o passado
e projetar um novo futuro através de
nossa própria ótica é o a profusa smo
oab o futurismo no final do dia é
absolutamente revolucionário e porque
ele é revolucionário
ele é revolucionário pelo simples fato
de unir dois elementos muito básicos
pessoas negras e futuro eo que tem de
tão especial e você une pessoas negras e
futuro porque porque isso me move por
que pensar em pessoas negras no futuro
me instiga porque pensar em pessoas
negras no futuro de latas minhas pupilas
para as minhas pernas em xerém de sangue
porque porque pensar em pessoas negras
no futuro pensar pessoas negras vivas
pensar em pessoas negras no futuro é
pensar que jovens negros conseguiram
desviar de 12 balas
ou essas balas não foram adiadas já que
jovens negros têm duas vezes mais
chances de morrer do que jovens brancos
pensar em pessoas negras no futuro
pensar que talvez mulheres negras não
tenham morrido tanto quanto morreram ano
passado afinal o genocídio contra a
mulher negra aumentou 54% das pessoas
negras no futuro pensar que não que
essas mulheres não morreram só por serem
negras e mulheres lançar em pessoas
negras no futuro é talvez entender que a
gente conseguiu superar coisas como
termos o corpo suspeito né que faz com
que pessoas negras sejam 78 por cento da
taxa de 10 por cento de mortes violentas
no brasil as pessoas negras no futuro
pensa que a gente superou a insegurança
ea desnutrição alimentar e que pessoas
não são as que mais morrem por diabetes
hipertensão e obesidade no brasil pensar
em pessoas negras e futuro é pensar que
a gente conseguiu vencer em que se a
encarceração em massa do povo negro e
talvez meu irmão estatística não vire
uma estatística que talvez irmão negro
jovem de 15 anos que anda de boné para
trás não acabe morto pela polícia que
talvez a minha mãe possa sair do ciclo
vicioso da narrativa de mulher forte e
guerreira sozinha que talvez eu e jovens
como eu tenho perspectivas futuras
tenham novas possibilidades
eu acho que todas as pessoas negras e
futuro pensar em um mundo em que as
pessoas negras conseguiram vencer a
baixa escolaridade em que pessoas negras
conseguiram entrar nas universidades e
que pessoas negras estão produzindo
conteúdo estão pensando sobre suas vidas
a partir de suas próprias óticas pensar
em pessoas negras futura pensar que
talvez a escravidão apesar de ter
tentado muito não conseguiu destruir
nossa herança cultural pensar em pessoas
negras e futuro é pensar em pessoas
negras vivas 4 turismo também é tão
importante porque ele a certeza de que
nós as minhas gerações presentes e às
futuras não serão a morte na praia do
nado de anos e anos dos nossos
ancestrais
o futurismo da minha tão revolucionário
porque ele é uma utopia e pessoas negras
precisam de utopias pessoas negras
precisam se enxergar pessoas negras
precisam construir possibilidades por
mais que ela
não imaginava esse como vamos todos
fugir para o espaço sideral por racismo
é [ __ ] pra [ __ ]
mesmo que esse seja o contexto é
necessário o apoio do turismo é tão
importante porque ele fala sobre futuro
um futuro em que pessoas negras estão
produzindo muito mais do que acreditam
que podem no futuro em que as pessoas
negras estão agindo mas acima de tudo o
agroturismo fala sobre o futuro e
pessoas negras estão limpas
obrigado